to enhance the beauty of a woman's face
and it was you know before this
generation before social media and all
these filters Etc it was about making
yourself look as natural as possible
enhancing what you already have yeah and
now we have a generation of people that
are all trying to look the same fulfill
the stick the same phenotype the same
prototype and it's you know it's highly
competitive because now you have as a
man you have access to thousands of
women that you would have never had 20.
wait top 20 of men have actually yeah
okay I mean I mean okay no no that's
what I'm saying so for example if you're
on an app or dating app you know you
wouldn't have even seen these women on
the street but you're seeing women maybe
in America right corner exactly of
course and the same for women a lot of
these women they wouldn't have had
access to these men's and this this
unrealistic expectation it's been
Amplified and magnified by social media
is unrealistic let's be honest as a
woman it's a lot of pressure though is
it not a lot of pressure to look a
certain way to fulfill a certain you
know it's because of the women the men
that
hey hey hey I was about to say for men
imagine they don't even have the makeup
they don't even have the finances to
wear the clothes and you know they might
put themselves in debt to just look good
for you you know what I mean so
but is it really that hard if there's
like 20 women who look like Kim K right
now you feel that you can take it six
and if she knows what she's doing with
her makeup she could look like him yeah
do you think do you think that women can
get a boob job and say they did it for
themselves yes
so you're telling me that women right
let's spend X amounts of money yes right
let's keep in mind money ain't cheap
you're working very hard for that money
so you're telling me women are spending
all that money to look out for
themselves
one at a time okay you go ahead no sorry
I mean I'm just saying I'm just saying I
personally think that's 100 possible
like without a doubt or even they're
women who unfortunately like sometimes
like don't like are are just don't have
any like don't have like proportionate
breasts to like their body they want to
feel like their body like they might
want to feel I don't know
about the conversation right now is
about whether women enhance themselves
for themselves
I can guarantee you right now every
single man on this PL um on this panel
right now can tell you that if when
they've been in a relationship you get
like maybe two three maybe four months
of your girl wearing makeup but after
that yo she's getting bare face and
she's looking at me sometimes she might
even look like a man you feel me like
about girls once they get comfortable
they are not wearing makeup you know
what that's like that's like if men got
got dick enhancements she said it was
for themselves
the princesses for anybody to enhance
their their sexual organs and say that
it's not for anybody else but themselves
has to be the biggest tease going like
it's like no genuinely I know you will
find me attractive but I'm not
interested in any single one of you so
just look at them don't find them just
look at them
want to want to be you know want it but
even I don't think can I just say this
to close all of this back and forth down
all you have to do is look at this how
many people access plastic surgery
because they have a burn or a mutation
versus how many people access cosmetic
plastic surgery and that's it that
closes that whole argument look how
cheap it is you can go to Columbia yeah
but you can get your own payment plans
like in the UK we're more likely to go
to Turkey Etc but my point is I'm not
trying to dismiss anyone's position
Edition but as a woman and I look at
other women and I see the plastic
surgery like on a day-to-day basis they
used to laugh at Michael Jackson some of
these women we see today they out they
out do my calls
no no I I mean in the in the in relation
to if you look at when you sit on the
train in the underground the amount of
women that have got lip fillers
enhancements of course you can do what
you want
but the reality is how many women are
paying paying for this stuff on payment
plans that means you could never afford
it you couldn't afford it even if it was
in Dominican Republic turkey or whatever
so what that shows me is that you are
folding to societal social conditioning
yeah exactly and social media your your
your being acquiesced into that kind of
behavior don't forget that they're dying
as well I think it's vanity honestly I
think it's vanity and entitlement and
not just like like I'm sorry if you're
born a five or six you're average that's
okay that's normal but the thing is like
women are so entitled they feel like
they're entitled to the top 20 percent
of men top 10 percent of men to be
honest I wouldn't say I'm a 10 but what
I was always to is aim higher right and
a lot of women they aim high when it
comes to men they aim high and they want
okay I agree they want the same types of
men they want the same category of men
um but with makeup plastic surgery this
gives them the opportunity in general
women opportunity to feel like they're a
10 or whatever and the problem with that
is in five years time you're gonna have
to go back to doctor and get a a retouch
Joe the Kardashian mess everything up
that costs money and if you date a woman
who has plastic surgery and you're the
Sole Provider that costs you money
that's that's the problem I have so if a
man falls in love with you because of
your image and you have plastic surgery
and he don't really know because a lot
of women don't tell and remember there's
a there's a man that sued a woman
because he had babies with her and the
babies came out that her original
no
this is really one he actually won the
case I think it was in like it was like
hey what should I Google man divorces
woman because of plastic surgery it's in
Asia I think so the children they came
out how how she originally looked more
oh my God wait wait she looks like a
different oh man I gotta I got a
blessing I gotta email this to you hold
on and just to close because you know I
think if you want to do plastic surgery
and some people do it for you know if
they have deformities Etc but when you
you know the bbls putting your life at
risk
what is that real sorry but you know I'm
sitting down yeah yeah so what is that
saying about your mindset you're willing
to risk your One Life to look a certain
way it's vanity
I think that actually shows it shows how
much better the world treats you when
you're a young attractive woman woman
and it shows it shows if anything it
shows that women are willing to die for
pretty privilege I guess I I don't okay
guys I'm gonna I'm gonna show I mean
it's sad but then like you know men just
have to deal with it like men don't get
that
um but wait she put it on screen because
this is crazy I can't even believe okay
okay can you
make it so they can see the reactions
okay okay it's the it's the ugliest
divorce in legal history when husband
Gian saw his newborn baby for the first
time he was horrified the girl was so
ugly he refused to believe that him and
His stunning wife could have produced
such a child
and he was rounded on his partner
accusing her of having an affair but she
told her him the terrible truth her good
looks were due to 62 000 pounds of
plastic surgery and the baby was indeed
the hit indeed theirs Furious Fang took
her to court claiming that she tricked
him into marriage and won the lawsuit
Fang said I married my wife out of love
but as soon as we had the first our
first daughter we began having marital
issues our daughter was incredibly ugly
to the point where it is
to the point to the point where it
horrified me his lawyers oh this is gold
thank you for telling me about this is
his lawyers told is he told his lawyers
his wife fooled him by having plastic
surgery to make her beautiful and it was
only the birth of their daughter that
gave it away incredibly the court agreed
and awarded Fang 75 000 pounds after his
wife admitted she had not told him about
the surgery a judge in nor a northern
Chinese Court said she had tricked Fang
into marrying her and granted a divorce
he also ruled that since Fang had not
been aware of the surgery his fight wife
had used false premises
and that is why and she and she gave him
back 75 you know all of his own money
you know what if she didn't enclose the
fact that she had surgery that's kind of
fraud still it's like the same way how
once again I'm a short man but if I get
surgery to be six foot and I told and I
don't tell the woman yeah I'm thinking
like I'm having NBA children exactly but
I'm like
yeah I'm gonna have to false advertising
yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible